we know
whether it's murder whether it's petty
theft whether it's just walking into a
cvs or walgreens and putting your arm on
the counter with the big bag and
stealing all the stuff or walking into
louis vuitton or give me another fancy
store
bloomingdales
thank you michael
that people are just walking into stores
and stealing [ __ ] and people don't want
to stop them and you can't sort of blame
these people because especially if you
live in a blue city where the district
attorneys are not going to prosecute
people or you're going to then be
you know put on trial for trying to do
your job or god knows what or they've
defunded the police and the police have
had enough of the abuse we know that
crime is exploding everywhere i mean go
to one of these cities i don't recommend
it really but like send somebody you
don't like to new york or san francisco
or la and see what's going on and and
you all just know it and that's directly
related by the way to this is my
favorite chart of the day uh we've got
some video here
about the california exodus and yes i'm
saying california so i'm going to throw
some money in the in the escape tally
fund and we're going to give it to
somebody at the end of the year who
wants to get the hell out of california
and move to florida but you can see this
is the estimated number of people
fleeing california and where they're
going
what's fascinating about this is i would
have thought that the uh that more
people the the circles that you're
seeing there uh that's where the
concentration of people are going i
would have thought more were ending up
in florida but that's you know that's
the 3 000 mile jump across the country
uh but most of the people are actually
ending up in texas and of course the the
question is are you going to vote the
right way
right so if you're a guy like joe rogan
it's like okay you were a bernie
supporter up in california when you
lived there you got the 200 mill from
spotify you realize you didn't want to
pay all the taxes now you move to texas
okay no state income tax you're going to
save a lot of dough but are you going to
make sure
that you vote for republicans not
because you have to be a republican but
you can't be a democrat and you know
this is where i always talk about the
liberals you can't rail against woke-ism
rail against critical race theory all of
the big government programs that have
destroyed the places you live and then
you can't go to the places that have
done it right and import those problems
and and if that's your plan then you
should stay in some of those places